hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts found in translation st2
from discovery to clinical adoption
presented by dr. jane schneider we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
believe in scientific social networking
website and provider a virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning for more
information please go to lab routes comm
on Christine Mihalik i'll be your
library's moderator today before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this is an event and it is
interactive we encourage you to submit
questions as you think of them just
click on the green Q&A button located in
the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question into the
box that appears on the screen will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
corner if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now I'd like
to introduce
dr. Jane Snyder dr. Snyder has been the
president of the critical care
diagnostics incorporated since august
2005 and serves as its member of the
management board prior to joining ccd in
august 2005 dr. Snyder served as an
executive vice president of business and
operations of intelligent medical
devices incorporated dr. Snyder joint
intelligent ND in October 2001's vice
president of marketing and business
development prior to I md dr. Snyder
served as a series of marketing and
product development positions at applied
biosystems also known as a bi in his
last role at ABI he managed the sample
preparation systems product line and
team from Genesis through product launch
and successfully established it in the
market before his eight-year tenor at a
B dr. Schneider served as senior
scientist at biotech research
laboratories a contract in service
research company specialized
specializing in retro violent
technologies he performed his
postdoctoral research as a fellow in the
biological response modifiers program at
the frederick cancer research and
development center at the National
Cancer Institute dr. Snyder holds a BS
in chemistry from grand valley state
university a PhD in chemistry from the
university of south carolina and an mba
in technology management from the
university of phoenix please join me in
welcoming dr. Jane Snyder I will now
turn the presentation over to him
okay thank you Christina appreciate that
kind introduction welcome everybody it's
certainly my pleasure to have an
opportunity to speak with you today and
present this material what I'm going to
be what I've prepared for presentation
today really is um I guess better
described as a case study in taking a
biomarker from the discovery phase all
the way through clinical implementation
so throughout the presentation today I'm
going to be interfering some very
technical clinical detail but that's not
used necessarily to make you experts in
the field that that we work with this
biomarker it's really intended to give
you perspective on the analytical
clinical technical requirements and
expectations around a biomarker
development program so in addition to
the clinical technical detail I'll be
also discussing some of the business and
regulatory elements as well some and in
none of the instances them I'm going to
go into great detail run because this is
not intended to be a true description
about for instance how to get a
regulatory approval for a test because
each test each product is unique but it
will give I'm hoping more of a
comprehensive representation of the
entire scope from again from discovery
to implementation so why don't we
proceed with the material so this slide
basically summarizes a biomarker assay
development program so critical care
diagnostics as you notice from this from
the title has focused on the biomarker
called st to st to is used in heart and
cardiovascular disease particularly in
heart failure and these are some of the
questions that you would need to address
as you're considering or adopted a
biomarker assay development program so
first is the analyte involved in a
disease so there are many ways to
address that
in the case of SD to it was found in
translation which means that the
investigators that first discovered that
sg2 was involved in cardiovascular
disease at a very unique cellular model
that emulated a certain form of cardiac
disease specifically heart failure and
then they looked at which genes were
upregulated in that model and
surprisingly st2 was upregulated prior
to that st2 was known to be involved in
other diseases but that novel discovery
that it was involved in cardiac disease
and in heart failure was unique and that
was the discovery and that was the
foundation for the intellectual property
that led to the formation of our company
I'm so and then you take that a step
further so it was involved in disease
what is the function of the analyte into
disease that's a much harder question to
answer and I'm going to touch on some of
the clinical analyses that we did to to
get a better understanding of that
question on what reagents exist to
measure the analyte is there a way to
measure it as I just mentioned the
original discovery was from gene
expression analysis so obviously that
was nucleic acid techniques principally
pcr and northern blot analysis but in
the clinical laboratory those are not
widely used technologies for routine use
so you need protein based assays for
blood tests or for other biological
fluids so those are typically antibodies
so do those exist or do they need to be
produced very importantly what are the
analytical requirements for measuring
this analyte is it stable is it unstable
what biological fluid is it president is
it is it a biological fluid that is easy
to obtain or something it would be very
difficult to obtain is it is it a high
concentration analyte or a low
concentration analyte for instance you
probably familiar with tests for cardiac
conditions like a myocardial infarction
and in the laboratory a very typical
test for an mi is troponin troponin is a
very low concentration
NY so those tests have to be very
sensitive other tests have much higher
concentrations of their analyte and
don't require that sensitivity so it's
really important that you have a
knowledge about the specific clinical
context and the requirements for how the
analyte is going to be used and then do
those reagents are those reagents
available to meet that requirement so if
you have antibodies are they good
antibodies do they have the right
affinity do they have the right
sensitivity and specificity all things
that have to be understood and
characterized the form factor is this a
test that needs to be done very rapidly
I'd mentioned troponin or myocardial
infarction now the nmi a myocardial
infarction or heart attack needs to be
treated quickly so you want an answer to
whether the patient who has chest pain
is truly having a myocardial infarction
as rapidly as possible certainly within
an hour so that you can begin the
appropriate therapy so a test that would
take four hours or five hours to
complete would not be an appropriate
solution for that problem however a test
that is not used for disease diagnosis
may not require such a rapid turnaround
and consequently a technique that might
give you better analytical performance
but takes more time might be a better
solution and those things all need to be
considered and I'll discuss that a
little bit in our experience and then
what is the business case you know is
there a true need for the test so is it
disease diagnosis is it establishing a
prognosis and a risk profile but the
patient going forward is it a companion
diagnostic and this is very common in
the cardia in the oncology world where
the therapies are very very expensive
and very specialized to unique clinical
conditions so there will be a test
that's specific for that condition that
would then define whether that therapy
would be implemented that doesn't exist
in cardiology but we still have the idea
of a complementary diagnostic routine
where can we use tests to evaluate
whether patients are responding to the
therapy that they're receiving
even though therapies are much more
generic are the patients responding to
these therapies or should we consider
something else so it really isn't the
companion diagnostic which would define
whether a patient should or shouldn't
get a specific therapy but whether the
patient is generally responding to
therapy or not so all of those things
have to be understood in order to even
determine whether your program is what I
look forward how you're going to go
forward with it what investment should
be made in the program which if possible
return and in future opportunities are
so this is a quick snapshot of where we
are from beginning to current with the
evolution of critical diagnostics so as
Christina said in the cover that company
was formed in 2004 that was based on
intellectual property patents that came
out of Harvard University and that was
around the use of st two in
cardiovascular disease for and then we
started we actually started operation of
the company in 2005 when I joined and
from 2005 until 2008 we worked to
develop our own proprietary set of
reagents based on experiences that we
learn from some what are called research
use only or arguable reagents so
reagents that are available from various
you know by about biotech companies but
not necessarily validated and not
necessarily used or even appropriate for
use in a clinical context but can
certainly be used in some instances to
understand the biology and maybe the
clinical context of the analyte that
you're interested in I'm in 2010 we
completed our development of our
proprietary SI system and had obtained a
definition of a clinical use and then we
move that into the regulatory process
obtaining our US FDA clearance for the
test for a first generation test which
was an immunoassay based on analyzer
format so an enzyme-linked immunosorbent
multi hour test that is usually involved
that is involved they're assuming
immunoassay system that uses antibodies
I'm in 2012 now we began to expand that
from the US from our US launch into
international sales effort and also
began development of a second-generation
product which was based on lateral flow
technology so very similar to the home
pregnancy test type of technology a
little bit more sophisticated in that
its quantitative and uses a an
instrument leader but a rapid test that
could emulate the performance of the
first generation test now another other
important elements are once you have a
test and getting FDA clearance or
regulatory clearance in whatever country
that you're trying to do business in is
necessary that's the first step in being
able to legitimately sell a product for
clinical use but then there are many
other steps that that need to be
achieved inclusion in the guidelines so
every medical field has a professional
guideline or a professional organization
in cardiovascular disease it's the
american heart association or aaha or
the American College of Cardiology the
ACC they combine to create guidelines
for every form of cardiovascular disease
and in 2013 st2 was first included in
the aah aacc guidelines for heart
failure management so that was a major
milestone of recognition that the test
has clinical value and was being
recognized by the professional
associations in the field in which we
produced the test that was followed up
by other requirements on in order to
pour the test to be used in the United
States one is to have an analyte
specific code for lab or products all
products have to have a code on the
analyte specific code is specific to
laboratory products and those are
defined and issued by the American
Medical Association there are very
specific expectations and requirements
in order for the AMA to initiative issue
such a code we were able to achieve that
in 2014 and then while
the code is issued CMS will make a
payment decision Center for Medicare and
Medicaid will make a payment decision
based on on those codes it may be
favorable to the manufacturer it may not
blew it through the process of
petitioning for a what we felt was a
fair and favorable payment decision and
we achieved we achieved that I'm so
early 2014 we got the Weaver CDN like
specific code Layton 2014 we received a
favorable payment decision by CMS in
2015 mom we obtained rce marks oce mark
is the european standard rate for
regulate regulation of clinical products
for our lateral flow product we obtained
that mark and clearance in 2015 began
marketing in Europe in 2016 and also
then use that siiii mark on standard to
begin market introduction in our Asian
partners it would currently do business
in about 40 countries around the world
so the US all of Europe under the sea
e-mark standard and in most Asian
countries with the exception of Japan so
that gives you a snapshot of you know
basically 11 years from the time in 2005
when we initiated truly initiated the
project until 2016 where we have two
products on the market and doing
business in multiple countries good so
let me tell talk just a little bit about
some of the technical details to give
you some perspective the challenges and
requirements in understanding defining
what it is that you're trying to do and
taking it through these various steps so
first and I've been this has just used
it for illustration of the complexity of
what some of these biomarkers can
represent so st2 is form of it is one of
the proteins in the interleukin-1
receptor superfamily it exists in two
forms as a membrane-bound form and a
soluble form and our test measures the
soluble form it's been known in the
literature and in science for many many
years since 1989 because of its
involvement in
the autoimmune disease states in part of
the t-cell modulation process so as I
mentioned to the discovery by the
investigators at Harvard that st2 was
also directly involved in cardiovascular
disease as part of a cardio Eric and
signaling mechanism was novel and unique
and that's the discovery that we
leveraged moving forward this cartoon
more clearly represents that where we
can see the nikatnite that the membrane
malformed soluble st 2l exist on the
cardiomyocyte membrane the cardio
fibroblast which is the second but more
more predominant cell type in the heart
expresses both st tu as well as
interleukin 33 in the context of a
diseased heart or us or a stressed
cardiomyocyte the cardiomyocyte is
looking for a protective signal through
it to loop in 33 which is expressed by
the cargo fibroblast so interleukin 33
would bind to the receptor form of st to
the myocyte then goes into a recovery
mode and response to therapy and
typically will will overcome the stress
or the disease that it's exposed to
however we close out of this in some
individuals an alternate pathway is is
initiated and in in this case the cardio
fibroblast may also up regulate the
expression of the soluble form which in
that case it binds interleukin 33 so
that it's no longer biologically
available to the receptor in that case
now that stimulated myocyte does not get
the protective signal from interleukin
33 and the myocyte then transitions into
an alternate response pathway of
apoptosis leading to necrosis fibrosis
in the tissue and worsening disease and
that's exactly the clinical response
that we see website when when patients
have an
in level of soluble st2 and the presence
of cardiovascular disease or symptoms of
cardiovascular disease so as we were
under trying to understand this in
clinical context our very first clinical
trial which was a trial of patients and
mute as you can see in this case about
600 patients that presented to the
emergency department of Massachusetts
General Hospital with symptoms of heart
failure so dis Mia is a formal phrase
for shortness of breath so these are
patients that have congestions in their
lungs they've got pressure in their
chest they're having trouble breathing
they typically you know cannot walk very
far they may even have difficulty pretty
just standing so they may present to the
hospital most of them have a history of
heart failure but they may also have
other diseases that can result in very
similar symptoms so other diseases that
can create similar symptoms would
include pneumonia which is a very common
co presentation and asthma acute
observation a COPD chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease exacerbation even a
myocardial infarction may but that's
much more rare so in these 600 patients
just over 200 were adjudicated diagnosis
of acute heart failure so that was of
course the syndrome that we were
interested in understanding better and
the other nearly 400 patients had other
other symptoms other syndromes resulting
in their shortness of breath now when we
look at this we do see now this is using
a research use test so that there's some
they were it turns out that we get no at
a time but there were some analytical
issues and performance characteristics
that were not I deal with those research
use reagents but we needed to use them
to get a better understanding of the
clinical context and the clinical value
of the biomarker so in this what we're
looking at in this box whisker plot is
the differential signal or
concentrations of st two in those
patients that have symptoms so they all
have some they're all sick with
something again about 200
them were diagnosed with acute heart
failure and their st2 concentrations are
higher than those patients who had
symptoms but did not have a keen heart
failure so just at first passed this
would look like there is a diagnostic
differentiation it's not absolute of
course the the perfect diagnostic test
would be positive in patients who have
the disease and negative in patients who
do not have the disease very few
diagnostic tests meet that criteria
there's usually some overlap of higher
concentrations in disease and lower
concentrations in the absence of disease
much more similar to what we see here
now if there was no other test for
diagnosis of the key heart failure this
may be good but there is a test there's
a test based around naturally peptides
there's two different forms BNP and
nt-probnp that's not important for this
discussion but those tests actually work
really well for a diagnosis of acute
heart failure so our first pass when we
looked at this there's a signal but it's
not better than an existing test so when
you think about your business case there
would not be probably reasonable
justification to pursue st2 as a heart
failure diagnostic test because it's not
superior to an existing well-established
product but what we saw is that not only
was st to concentration one st two
concentrations elevated in the presence
of disease but it also they also
correlated with the severity of symptoms
so the New York Heart Association class
is a representation of these is the
symptom severity so there's force
there's four steps we very few patients
present to the emergency department with
the lowest level of symptoms which is
category one most present with with
symptoms at the categories level two
through four in the most severe is level
four so those are the sickest patients
symptomatically there's another scale a
through D that represent the underlying
pathophysiology of the disease or the
stage of the disease so in most cases
you
to take both the scale and the new
apprentice OCA Shin class symptom
representation to get a real reflection
but symptom presentation is important so
st2 is higher in patients who are sicker
so that's important and then
surprisingly and this was the
observation that we ended up recognizing
as the unique clinical and potentially
the business value proposition with st2
was it's very powerful prognostic value
so this is an analysis that's called
kaplan-meier kaplan-meier survival and
what we're looking at here is a st to
concentration at a specific
concentration and then whether patients
that were above or below that
concentration what their mortality
events were over a period of time in
this case for one year so the salad bar
shows that below a certain concentration
only one patient died in one year and
that patient was after six months so it
shows that patients even though they're
sick they're presenting with disease in
this case we're looking at the patients
with acute heart failure so there they
were sick enough to go to the emergency
room they already had underlying disease
but if they're st to concentration was
low and they obtained that they received
therapy their risk of mortality over the
year was very low begin balloon one
patient died by contrast if they're st
to concentration was modestly elevator
or maybe even significantly elevated now
they had a much much higher risk of
mortality and in many cases very rapidly
it turned out that s T 2 is a very
powerful predictor of short-term risk
within 30 days which is a time frame
that is actionable for doctors that are
seeing these patients that's interfering
where they can make changes to therapy
monitor the patients and then assess
going forward 1-year mortality or be
longer is much much more difficult to
manage clinical so this discovery then
gave us a differentiation we didn't have
a differentiation based on diagnosis of
disease but we had a very clear and
powerful differentiation of this marker
for
existing tests or existing parameters in
evaluating heart failure patients to
establish a tool or prognosis now
prognosis though of course it is only
useful if you can do something about it
you know having a patient come in and
saying well you know you've got a
threefold higher chance of dying within
one year you know you know thank you for
coming it's not an effective clinical
management technique we have to be able
to do something about it and as we get
further into the presentation will
describe what we've discovered about
about doing that but one of the things
that we had to do was also evaluate what
reagents we were going to use the weight
forward so once we established that
there was clinical value in having an ST
to test then we had to evaluate whether
we would use some of the existing
reagents or whether we would need to
develop our own and whether the existing
reagents at the right performance so
first moment is going to put the put dis
reference out and this was published
several years ago I'm back in twenty
twelve by nadir raphe nadir at the time
was the editor-in-chief of the journal
clinical chemistry which published this
nadir is also the head of the laboratory
at Brigham and Women's Hospital in
Boston and what he pointed out in this
in this editorial article is that
investigators can be significantly
mislead and the field can be misled by
using research use reagents if there's a
characterized and validated test
available the difference is that many of
the use research use creations might be
perfectly functional they may they may
work well but those producers those
manufacturers usually only go through
very modest validation and
standardization protocols and
consequently you may not be you may not
understand or recognize that those tests
could be affected by inhibitors that
naturally occurring your biological
specimens
they may not be as specific to the
analyte that you're interested in they
may be compromised by sensitivity and
that was one of the things that we learn
as we were moving forward is that the
research use reagents that we were using
do because they had not been fully
characterized and when I validated did
not provide the tree performance that
was necessary for a clinically used test
so we had to go through a program to
develop our own reagents it's these kind
of protocols are a fairly routine
there's many techniques and service
companies that can do the production of
an antigen what will become a protein to
use as an antigen to raise antibodies
companies that can then take that
antigen and make antibodies companies
that can characterize the antibodies and
so on so we obtained you know or source
those projects to those companies
developed our reagents and then we had
to determine what format we wanted to
use Eliza is the generic most standard
first generation format it's very easy
to do it's not a fast test it typically
takes four to six hours to perform
analyze a test but you can do multiple
specimens per plate it's a 96-well plate
typically colorimetric with luminescent
technologies are the normal options
chloro metric is particularly easy then
it's widespread it doesn't require any
unique instrument systems you know no
equipment but it's not as it has
relatively modest sensitivity
luminescence isn't much more sensitive
much more precise technique but is a
more specialized equipment lateral flow
there's also a reasonable technique it's
widely used it can be adapted quickly
but it has some performance
characteristics that may not be
completely unsuitable to initial
characterization of a test some of those
compromises our absolute sensitivity
usually requires fairly high cotton
erations of an analyte to accurately
measure and it's a relatively noisy
technology so getting good precision is
that there is a is a challenge with
collateral flow it's not impossible that
it's not easy well of course the major
companies you know the abbot's rocha's
and so on at the world have the
homogeneous automated assays done which
are very very nice but those programs
can take multiple years on a typical
development program from discovery and
an identification of your reagents to
validation they take two to three years
for those large instruments and
integrated instrument instrument systems
and if you're trying to understand what
your bio marker is and what your
clinical context is that may be too long
a period of time to do assay development
before you begin doing your your
clinical validation so he Liza is a
typical technique that's used and that's
the technique that we used now when we
were evaluating our reagents and we
picked our reagents one was for
performance but also for control if we
were going to build a test we had to
make sure that the reagents that we're
going into our test because we are the
manufacturer of record we had to know
that the quality of those materials was
consistent over time and that we could
you defend the production of this test
to go to go into the market so rather
than relying on a third party source of
these reagents that we weren't didn't
have high confidence in any way we do
produced our own and in some of our
first analyses we discovered that the
performance was profoundly different and
we saw two things here here no I don't
expect you to understand all the details
in this table but if we look at the
columns of the MBO which was the
research use reagents that we use and
ccd which is our reagents there's a huge
difference in the numbers so the it
turns out that our tests was about 60 to
100 times more sensitive than the NBL
reagents at first I wasn't sure they
whether we were measuring you know other
Reles maybe maybe the two tests were
we're not actually measuring the same
analyte with further investigation we
learned that in fact we were measuring
the same analyte but again one of the
things that is a point of emphasis if
you're in a biomarker discovery
development program is understanding
your analyte in this instance we made
the the the common of protein which was
used as the antigen for our antibodies
we we did a human expression system so
the antigen that was used to make our
antibodies was as close to the native
protein as we could possibly get in a
recombinant system the research use
tests used different expression systems
that were eukaryotic but we're not Cuban
and because this is a highly
post-translationally modified protein
the antigenicity is different this the
the sensitivity and the affinity of the
antibodies is different and consequently
you get very different performance of
your test so our test that was made to
the human characteristics of the protein
bed again much much higher sensitivity
in was not as sensitive to certain
inhibitors so in this case if we compare
EDTA plasma to heparin plasma we see
that heparin completely obliterated the
sensitivity of the research use tests
but had no effect on our test and that's
very important because in the field of
cardiac cardiovascular disease patients
are very frequently treated with heparin
as an anticoagulant and in further
analysis we discovered that that the MBL
test was so sensitive to the inhibitor
that even to heparin that even there are
puted concentrations of heparin affected
the test so that those kind of things
can compromise your clinical
interpretation and need to be understood
so this was an observation that we made
early on and further gave get us further
justification that using our own
reagents was going to give us both a
business advantage as well as a clinical
performance advantage as we moved into
into our validation
interestingly though if we look at a
method comparison technique this is a
standard statistical method comparison
technique called passing babolat where
we're simply looking at whether the two
tests you give you comparable
interpretations and in fact they do so
the regardless of which tests are using
if an SD to concentration is elevated
elevated in both of them the absolute
number is going to be different but high
is high and low is low and they and they
and they compared in that kind of a
crude crude comparison another
comparison technique and this is also
very standard in the diagnostics of at
test development and use protocols this
is called receiver operator Kirk
analysis and what we're looking at is a
reflection of a tests sensitivity and
specificity or a specific question in
this question we were looking at
mortality in one year so whether
patients survived or did not survive
over one year now the perfect test would
have an area under the curve which is
there's the area to the right of the
curve of one so you want the this parent
to be perfectly vertical on the y-axis
and perfectly horizontal across the top
of the x-axis and that would give you an
area of one under the curve in this case
we see that our area under the curve is
0 point 8 just a little bit above point
8 for each essay so again if st2 is
elevated you get a accurate
representation of a risk of an love in
this case an outcome of death and both
tests can do that but the next slide we
see that the optimal concentration is
about 100-fold different between the two
tests our test measures at a calibrated
value of 27 nanograms per mil and when
we caught 22 nanograms per mil well the
other test and again these two tests are
not you cannot compare numbers between
the two these two tests because they are
not calibrated the same there are there
is no bold standard calibration or st to
as an analyte that was something that we
had to do as well
so we see that you can that the the
biomarker is consistent what changes is
how accurately and how consistently you
can measure it based on the two tests
now as we move forward and this is one
of the requirements for definition of a
biomarker in any other clinical
laboratory test and that is whether you
can measure it in normal individuals if
there's a distinction between normal
reference populations and disease
populations so in this analysis we
summarized measuring two groups the
first group was a small group about 400
consume me about 500 individuals that
were self-declared to not have any
cardiovascular disease we're not being
treated for cardiovascular disease and
we'll self-declared healthy and then
those that analysis was followed up with
in with over 3,000 individuals from the
framingham heart failure study which
were also self-declared as well as
clinically identified to be healthy
individuals that were not currently when
diagnosed with disease or being treated
for disease and you can see that in
these two cohorts we get very very
similar numbers using our tests now in
this case you could be compromised using
research use degree agents now because
basically the median invite based on our
test is the limit of detection of the
research use tests so half of the normal
population is effectively unmeasurable
using research use tests and there's
several clinical clinical trials that
have used research use tests that have
confirmed this observation further our
ibly had to have some mechanism to
define a threshold concentration that
the FDA wanted for us to use as we went
into non clinical validation now unlike
a diagnostic test again which you know
the ideal diagnostic test would be
elevated in patients with disease and
would be very low or undetectable in
patients without disease so if you can
detect it then
you would be positive for the disease
with a prognostic test it's not so
simple because you can have on high risk
in the presence of disease low risk in
the presence of disease and you can
actually have measurable concentrations
of an analyte with no disease and that's
what's shown in this in this primary
reference cohort is that concentrations
can range from very low single-digit you
nanogram vanilla the minimum value that
was seen was you know two nanograms per
mil all the way up to you know over 100
nanograms per note now that's an
individual that probably has priests of
genetic disease which we've learned
since we did this but but again these
are help you self declared healthy
individuals hmmm but the FDA wanted us
to find a cut point that could be used
to provide guidance to positions at how
to use the test so we elected move to
use a strategy of dividing that coupling
based on higher concentrations in the
normal asymptomatic population so we
picked the approximately to 95th
percentile who which in this analysis
was shown at 37 nanograms per milk just
for ease we picked 35 nanograms per milk
and then use that concentration in
various clinical trials to validate its
performance as a cut point or prognosis
in patients with heart failure so moving
into a definition now of the disease
state that we needed to define the use
of the biomarker it if you're moving
into a regulatory process your course
going to study the biomarker or your
test in multiple disease states multiple
syndromes but neat but it's not
reasonable and probably not even not
even possible to get multiple clinical
clearances you really need to define a
specific question and a specific
objective in order to get a clinical
clearance through the FDA or through any
other regulatory body so based on both
our clinical evidence as well as the
advice of our advisory board the key
opinion leaders and specialists in the
area it was understood and
we pursue the utility of st two in
managing patients with heart failure so
leveraging the prognostic power of st to
as a heart failure management tool okay
so going back to again that first study
now using our validated test we see that
we get exactly the same profile that s T
2 concentrations are higher in patients
that have diagnosed disease heart
failure then in patients who have
symptoms but do not have diagnosed
disease so begin the potential
diagnostic but not a powerful diagnostic
same profile of association with symptom
severity higher concentrations in acute
heart failure so worse symptoms and
worst disease you get higher
concentrations but you get the trend in
both acute heart failure which are
hospitalized patients as well as in
chronic heart failure which these
patients are not hospitalized this is a
community cohort of patients that are
being treated as outpatients with what
is perceived as stable heart failure in
those now in this case you would also
expect that a prognostic test would not
be binary again just because you're
above a certain concentration doesn't
mean you go from no risk to absolute
risk there's going to be some grades of
risk as a function of concentration if
your test or if the biomarker is
performing appropriately and that's
exactly what we see with st 2 is that in
very low concentrations we have a very
low risk profile then once you cross the
threshold then this arrow indicates
essentially that 35 nanogram per no
threshold and then as we increase
concentrations by decile we get to a
very very high risk greater than a
50-percent risk of 1-year mortality at
the highest concentrations so it so it
provides you something that's
informative potentially actionable
certainly informative on what what this
patient's biological profile is in the
context of their disease just like we
saw with the initial kaplan-meier curve
but now focusing you know to the left on
that 30-day power is that if st 2
concentrations are elevated or not
you know low-paid patients with the
lowest teach you that receive treatment
have a very low risk of short-term
mortality but patients with elevated st
to even in the presence of obtaining
therapy in this case standard therapy
not biomarker defined therapy but
standard therapy still have a very high
risk of locality as is this something
that can be addressed and that's an area
that we need to explore further just
like in the US population know this is a
European population who where we look at
the risk of death or heart failure
hospitalizations so another very
meaningful endpoint in managing patients
with heart failure is how frequently
they get be hospitalized because
hospitalizations are both very expensive
and very dangerous to the patients and
what we've seen in this case is that
within in elevated sg2 as a 17 full of
higher risk of being be to dying or
being readmitted within 30 days than
losutu and that risk is persistent out
to one-year follow-up and this was from
a European cohort so clinically we do
not see any differences in the biomarker
between populations in different
countries or different regions so US
population behaves the same as the
European population behaves the same as
a Chinese population so that you know
there's no ethnic or in this case
regional you know clinical differences
between between populations which that's
also very important in understanding how
your bio marker or how your test
performs now a test also needs to be
consistent so this is a summary analysis
from three different cohorts these are
all ambulatory heart failure cohorts
there well managed outpatients the first
to the barcelona and the phff that's
pent heart failure study these are
community cohorts these are all comers
these are patients and they have a wide
spread of different underlying
ideologies to their disease they're
being managed at different levels across
a much broader age spectrum etc so
they're very representative of the
normal pocket of new normal disease
population but it's sicker population
than bike
Barisan to the age of action who hf
action was a randomized control trial
and in this case the therapy that was
being evaluated was exercise so these
are patients who do have heart failure
they are being managed for heart failure
but they were healthy enough to be able
to participate in some form of physical
activity so an exercise level as part of
their their therapy now so this is a
much less sick cohort than the other two
but what you see in both the left which
is a univariate analysis you're only
looking at the power of st to at the
threshold concentration of 35 nanograms
per mil to predict mortality in one year
the values are the same across all three
cohorts and if you look at it the right
panel which is a fully risk-adjusted
model so it includes that the key 11
different variables the New York art
association class age gender body mass
index renal function etc it attenuates
the power of st to a little bit from you
know hazard ratio of over four to a
hazard ratio of three which is normal
you know when you include more variables
in your risk model you are going to see
an adjustment of the power of any
specific variable but the consistency
across the three cohorts remains
constant and that's important they that
you're not seeing variations you know in
the utility or the function of a test
the from sources of your of your test
subjects it's very consistent so that
provides a lot of confidence in peace of
mind to the clinicians and also to the
regulatory agencies as they're
evaluating the performance when this
kind of consistency can can be
demonstrated okay so taking that
knowledge we did go to to the FDA and
some of the advice you know that I tried
to intersperse in this in this section
mmm was preparing to do that so the
first thing is to work closely with the
FDA the FDA will certainly have dialogue
with you they have a formal process to
do that but it is a process that is
readily available you can meet with them
you can ask questions they won't tell
you
exactly what to do but they will you
know if you make it and if you make a
suggestion that's just crazy they'll
give you some indication that it's a
crazy idea they won't come right out and
say that but they'll give you
indications that you might want to try
something different and though and
they'll give you some ideas of exactly
what kind of things that they need and
then if you follow that your probability
and you can end your test and achieve it
so you follow their guidance and you can
actually show the data to achieve what
they're suggesting your probability of a
successful your transit through the FDA
is good but you do need to know your
analyte you do need to know your test
all the things that I just described
they're just a snapshot of what they're
going to expect to see from your test
performance from the perform the
characteristics of your analyte how
where it is a disease in the disease
you're interested in and other syndromes
and so on you need to be able to answer
those questions and then have that clear
and convincing evidence of the
performance of the test and the utility
of the test so that there's something
actionable okay because the FDA is
focused on two things primarily on
safety you know is this test going if if
a decision is made on the test is there
a risk to the patient so you have to be
able to answer that question you have to
show that that risk is understood if
there is risk and what the consequences
would be and then is it clinically is it
clinically useful that's less of a
question for the FDA that's more of a
question for CMS but it's an important
question for us as a developer of a
product to show that not only do you get
safety and effectiveness but there's
utility so what would be the utility of
a prognostic test so as I mentioned you
know being able to establish the risk of
an adverse event whether it's mortality
hospitalization worsening disease you
know whatever your definition of
prognosis or risk is being able to
define that is interesting but unless
you can do something about it like for
diagnosis if you diagnose
that defines how that patient is going
to be treated prognosis is not so
clear-cut typically there are many
different techniques the Framingham
Heart score for instance is a technique
to define in an asymptomatic individual
what that person's risk is of developing
cardiovascular disease in the next
decade but there's no clarity about what
you would do about that so in if you're
developing at a laboratory test where
somebody is going to pay money to warm
the test you're going to get a value
what are you going to do with that value
to affect the future of this patient so
disease monitoring and therapy
monitoring and treatment selection would
be the obvious utilizations for a quad
Gnostic test so is st2 useful in that
pic in that environment so this is just
one example from a randomized control
trial this is from the veil hep study
Val heft was a evaluation of a very
large cohort over 5,000 patients for
drug called valsartan narb for reducing
mortality morbidity and locality in
patients with chronic heart failure the
samples were collected at multiple time
points in this analysis we're looking at
measuring st2 in patients at enrollment
so that's the baseline value and then a
second value collected full of months
later and what we're looking at in this
case is the risk in patients as a
function of whether they're st to value
changed or didn't change over that four
month period of time so because this was
a stable cohort we would expect so that
most of the patients would have lowest
you too and that's true that in there
were over 1100 patients that were it was
the u.s. subset of this cohort it was a
multinational trial we only looked at
the US patients and then those patients
where specimens were available because
they didn't collect blood samples from
every patient in the study so this was a
buddy 1100 patients from this for 5000
patient cohort but they were stable
ambulatory patients so st2 was alone and
that's the low too low group now we have
three other groups of
the persistently high group so patients
that had st2 above 35 at both time
points or what we call late changes
patients who were started out high and
low above or below 35 or the converse
low to high and what we see is that in
the patient we used the persistently low
group as the reference so there hazard
ratio was set to 1 and then each of the
other groups were compared to that and
we see that if the patient was
persistently high there are much higher
risk seventy percent higher risk of an
adverse event mortality in this case or
if they went from low to high they were
even higher risk and ninety percent
increase risk but the patients who were
persistently low or were high in went
low had essentially the same you know
the level of risk so so we're so we get
the first nap shot here that that
monitoring the change in st to all the
time would potentially be useful we
don't have any information about therapy
here we only know from this analysis
that the changes possibly is possibly
useful and that's been been confirmed in
now multiple analyses of cereal testing
and changing is that a point measurement
is valuable but a change over time is
even more representative of the
patient's disease state and whether
their disease is is responding to
therapy potentially improving or at
least not getting worse or if their
disease is getting worse now if you come
to the business case analysis you know
one of the things that doctors are
always concerned about is if you give
them a new test and they're already busy
you know the doctors us if we've been to
the to a doctor's appointment you
usually get 15 to 20 minutes with your
doctor and they're booked every day so
if you give them a test that's going to
wreak a tagore eyes their patients are
is this going to fill up there they're
waiting room with patients that are
going to even exceed their capacity now
and in this case we did the math and it
turns out know that it actually helps
them more effectively manage their
patients because you can very
confidently identify those patients that
are lower risk which in this case is
basically eighty percent
of the patients were either in a
low-risk or moved to a lower risk
category patients that could be a may be
monitored or managed more in infrequent
visits by contrast again we've redefined
twenty percent of these patients in this
very large population that are higher
risk and probably justified having more
aggressive follow a pattern and more
changes to their medications so so you
actually can use the tool to more
effectively manage your allure census of
patients than they currently are through
standard of care and pretend symptom
observational mmm now another analysis
this was done by a group at mayo medical
clinic in a cohort of 200 patients where
they were seen every four months for two
years looking at mortality as an
endpoint and evaluated the three top
biomarkers for managing patients with
heart failure which is st to B&P one of
the net Rhoda peptides and cardiac
troponin and the question they were
asking was whether serial testing
testing at each one of those time points
was a better utilization or would
measuring only one marker be more
powerful and what this shows is that the
highest hazard ratio was achieved by
doing serial testing of st to alone so
that the greatest bit most the most
accurate risk assessment was with serial
testing of st to alone when other
markers were added when B and P was
added and then when troponin was added
the hazard ratio decreased meaning that
the accuracy prediction decreased with
the addition of the of the other data so
so that the conclusion from this type of
analysis and again this comes to the
business case is that how would you
recommend using the test well BNP and
troponin are outstanding tests for what
they tell you about the patient's
disease BNP tells you about emo dynamic
status stretch and volume troponin tells
you about cardiomyocyte turnover and
necrosis though it their great point
measurement tests but they're not as
good for serial testing as st2 is so
when you go into a payment scenario
you're not telling the
lab or the insurance companies that they
need to measure each of these tests each
time certain times they would measure
all three and then certain times you
would measure just one of them so it
gives you two justification to go into
those kind of financial discussions with
the various entities now of course as
you move into the heart failure was a
very complex syndrome you know most of
what I've talked about is focusing on
later stage heart failure stage c and d
heart failure patients and these are
patients would clearly diagnosed active
treated and heart better that's being
treated however the earlier stages of
disease stage B is that stage where
somebody has had an event and and we're
moving into potential therapy and risk
management so in this case st2 meal was
monitored and we're in the highest risk
category was at 35 nanograms per mil
which is our threshold so in debt it
occurs naturally within the population
and now you can use that to go forward
and I'm another observation of change
over time and potential therapy and this
is a cohort of patients that were
hospitalized for heart failure they were
discharged and then we looked at whether
they're st to change to during their
hospitalization and whether they
responded to a certain therapy so if
they're st to level did not change they
had a very interesting if the r st tune
level did not decrease they were
clarified as a non responder and a high
risk and that's number four if they if
they're Institute level decreased they
were classified as a responder and
that's a category number one now in the
outpatient environment some of these
patients receive beta blocker and some
agents received other therapies if they
were a low risk an SD g responder which
was lines one and three there's no
statistical difference but if there s
teaching level if they were a
non-responder but they got therapy on
the increased therapy from as an
outpatient their risk profile changed so
what this tells us is that you can use
the test
to attenuate and modify risk that it is
actionable it's not just enacted in a
question and those are the areas that
we're now moving into for further
clarification and adjudication and I'll
wrap up with just me a one case study
analysis of a typical heart failure
patient an 85 year old individual with
mild you know symptomatic heart failure
very typical atrial fibrillation but
based on the standard heartfilia
biomarker nt-probnp it's a stable
patient it's elevated but it's not
diagnostically elevated because this is
a patient who has disease so they're
they're being there NT propia p should
be at about that level over a series of
visits his nt-probnp level is constant
no indication that this patient is at an
increased risk over anybody else in the
cohort he's he's ambulatory he's
recording feeling okay and he's
responding to his therapy or at least
tolerating his therapy but when st2 was
measured we see that his st to LA was
quite high almost 80 that's a very high
concentration for a stable heart failure
patient so based on that observation in
this case the doctor who's an expert in
biomarkers started modulating his
therapy increasing beta blocker at
various doses and this was a patient who
who's be was already mildly hypotensive
at local had had low blood pressure so
there was a concern that he may not
tolerate the higher beta blocker but he
did admin increased dose of ACE
inhibitor got his st to level below 35
stabilize the patient so now we see if
we just use STG we get a very clear
response profile over a series of visits
and in this patient stabilized tolerated
the increased medications very well
reported feeling better and a year later
had no hospitalization to or adverse
events now some of the areas that and
I'll touched on this previously was you
know moving forward so we established
the Eliza as our first method that's not
being used around the world moving
forward we needed a more appropriate
test for rapid turnaround time even
though st 2 is a prognostic
test so short turnaround time is not an
absolute requirement but many
laboratories don't like to do eliza so a
test that's more appropriate to every
hospital that provides a more reasonable
one hour turnaround time was important
so we start evaluating technology that
we could have access to that wasn't
encumbered by other intellectual
property and that's lateral flow so we
have the reagents to do that so we
answered that question we know the
animal we know the analytical use
requirements so could we develop a test
to do that which said we already have
the reagents to do it we know the form
factor we know where it's going to be
used how it's going to be used and then
could we develop a business case to do
that which we did work on and now that
project that test has been as i showed
in the first slide has been introduced
under CEO mark we're now working on our
FDA submission and where are sort of
already on the market but that test in
most Asian countries and above to go on
the market in China and through their
regulatory processes so just one last
slide on project management and how you
would approach these types of projects
now if you're a row sure they had an
Abbott you've got the resources to do
this internally if you're an earlier
stage company or in the case of critical
Diagnostics a startup company to do this
the you have to think about what what do
you do and what do you all source so we
took the strategy of only doing the
things ourselves where we add value so
fundamental research fundamental product
development and certainly manufacturing
are not things that we are good at we
don't have the resources to develop
those processes so we also us all of
that man there's in the area of you know
essays and diagnostics there's many many
many options to pursue that there's
capabilities for every step of the way
very strong companies and research
institutions that can do this you know
whether those companies have the
equipment and facilities the capacity
whether they're aligned with your
priorities you have to decide those
things and then who's going to handle QA
and regulatory which of course that's
one of the areas that we take
because we are the manufacturer of
record so with that I will conclude and
sorry that I did run over a little bit
but I'd be happy to try to answer any
questions that have come up thank you
dr. Schneider for that informative
presentation however since we are
running short on time today we will not
be able to take any questions from the
audience I would like to say thank you
and ask if you do you have any final
comments other than your your conclusion
thank you Christina I don't have any
additional comments I think I ain't
rejected my recommendations and
observations throughout the presentation
so again hopefully this was helpful that
was my pleasure and have a great day
excellent thank you before we go I want
to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through februari 2017 you will
receive an email from lab groups letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay and please share
the announcement with your colleagues
who may have not been able to attend
today's live events thank you for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon here at lab roots
goodbye